مراسم مسلمي الان بعد التوقيع ما هي
ترتيبات التي ستلي هذه المراسم والتوقيع
على هذا الاتفاق الاطاري
نعم هو الان تم التوقيع على الاتفاق
الايطالي بين المكون العسكري وبعض القوه
السياسيه المدنيه
المكونه من المجلس المركزي للحريه
والتغيير هذه ابرز هذه القوه وهو منقوصا
منه طبعا حزب البحث العربي الاشتراكي الذي
رفض هذا الاتفاق وهنالك قوى كثيره تعارض
هذا الاتفاق الاتفاق في مجمله تمكنت القوه
المدنيه في مجملها ان تنال ال- ال-
المبادئ التي كانت تناضل من اجلها وكانت
تنادي بها المتعلقه بالحريات العامه وحقوق
الانسان والاصلاح المؤسسي الى غير ذلك
ولكن الاتفاق بالرغم من انه اشار الى
قضايا في صلبه الى انه ارجع خمسه قضايا
اخرى مطلوب ان يدار حول حوار مستقبل لم
يحدد من يحاضر مع هذه المجموعه ولكن موضوع
العداله الانتقاليه والعداله الجنائيه
موضوع
ازاله التمكين موضوعه تصاحل المؤسسات
العسكريه موضوع الشركه السودان موضوع
السلامه الى غير ذلك كلها همم يفترض ان
يدار حول حوار بين الجهات المتفق على هذا
الاتفاق وجهه اخرى لم يعلن عنها بشكل واضح
ولا ندري هل ستقبل هذه الجهات الرافضه
لهذا الاتفاق ان تنخرط في حوار من جديد
حول نفس هذه المضامين والمعاني على كل حال
الاتفاق من الواضح انه منح القوه المدنيه
همم حقوق كثيره وان القوه العسكريه
المقاومه العسكريه تراجع فعلا الى سكناته
من خلال هذا الاتفاق ان تطبق هذه الاتفاق
عمليا هنا استطاعت القوه التي اليها والتي
وقعت عليها ان تنزله على الواقع ان تنزله
على الارض ان استطاعت ان تفعل ذلك في ان
المكون من العسكري عمليا يرجع الى سكناته
ولم يقول له دور فيهم الا مع حكومه مدنيه
همم في مجلس القلب الدفاع الذي راسه
الوزراء ويشارك فيه فقط المكونه العسكري
في بقائد الجيش وقائد الدعم السريع ولكن
المعارضه واسعه لهذا الاتفاق
والمعارضه تصف هذا الاتفاق
عنه بالذات يعني المعارضه التي تطعن فيش
في هذا الاتفاق قد لا ترى اي ربما اختلاف
بينما يقال الان حول ان المجلس العسكري
يسلم السلطه للحكم المدني وبين ما قيل
ايضا في اتفاقات سابقه وبالتالي السؤال
هنا هل هناك فوارق فعليه همم تبدو في هذا
الاتفاق عامه تم الاتفاق عليه سابقا
المعارضه تعترض على اشياء كثيره من هذا
الاتفاق اهمها انها تعتبر هذا الاتفاق
مجرد تسويه ثنائيه اخصائيه امليت على
السودان بقوه اجنبيه ان هذا الاتفاق لم
ينتج عن حوار سوداني بل هذا الاتفاق فرض
فرضا على السودان قبلت به القوه التي
تتعاون مع ال مع الخارج ورفضت هذه القوه
باعتباره انه هذا الاتفاق اسقط السياده
السودانيه في ان تتحكم في مصيرها هذه من
اهم النقاط التي تعرضها المعارضه ولكن
صلبه الاتفاق نفسه يعارض فمثلا الوقوف على
مسافه واحده من كل الاديان وكريمه
المعتقدات يعتبره الاسلام المسلمون اللي
هو اكثر من 99% من شعب السودان يعتبره
اخصاء للشريعه الاسلاميه واخسار لدور
الاسلام في الحياه العامه وهذا مرفوض
واعتباري هذه تسلط الماني وهذا تركيز وزعي
الى ثقافه علمانيه خارجيه على الشعب
السوداني غير ذلك فان الاتفاق يقول ان
القوى الموقعه على على على الاعلان
الدستوري هي التي هي التي تعين مجلس عدلي
مؤقت هو الذي يعين او هو الذي يعيد ترتيب
السلطات القضائيه وسلطات النائبه العام
والمحكمه الدستوريه الى ذلك ويعتبرون ان
ذلك تدخل سياسي مباشر في القضاء لا يضمن
من بعض هذا التدخل ان يكون القضاء عادلا
لان الذين عينوا كبار القضاه والذين عينوا
قضاه المحكمه الدستوريه او النائب العام
هو مكون سياسي مختلف سياسيا مع جهات اخرى
وبالتالي ستفرض وجهه نظر هذا السياسي
ورؤيته ال- ال- القانونيه او السياسيه من
خلال القضاء وهنالك ايضا تخوف خاصه من
الجهاز من الجهات التي وقعت على اتفاقيه
السلام القوه التي كانت تقاتل الحكومه
وقعت على اتفاقيه السلام هنالك تخوف لان
الاتحاد لا لا لان
الاتفاق يا نوص على مراجعه تقويم وتقييم
هذه الاتفاقيه معهم ولكن هم لا يدرون كيف
يمكن لم يجري حوار يجرح حوار حول كيف يمكن
ان تقيم وتقوم هذه الاتفاقيات لذلك لا
تخوفون هذا الاتحاد هذا الاتفاق يواجه
حقيقه ستبقى معنا المسلمون